No!
So Emil you won the previous game
What kindof strategy are you going to take this time?
I think I'll take the exactsame strategy
And the Joker
And what happens if you hit the Joker?
You getto hit 3 balls at once with the next shot
Let's put this one here then
Actually no, that'stoo easy. That's like too obvious!
Okay now i have my balloons ready
Time for the needles
It's so intense!
Well, at least I know my needles are working
Last time this didn't go too well with Emil...
What happened there emil?
Nothing
Let's see if he has learned anything
I think that's good!
Zero casualties
Are you ready Emil?
Are you ready? I'm ready!
It's time for the grand final and
I'm quite excited!
I'm going to win this one!
Yeah you are on the winning side
And youget to start
So I have no chance
You sound like Mr. Excuses for this
Okay let'sstart!
It hit the edge, did it?
No, it didn't!
I like that sound!
That was the Joker
Okay Otto are you ready to hear some
more popping?
Yeah
The air strike!
Not even one!
You missed the airstrike
You can almost hear the pop in your head
But then there is no pop!
Now you will hear a pop for real!
Just in your mind
You clearly came to win today!
I know how to play this game!
3-0!
It's starting to look abit empty your side of the table!
I know
That's only harder for Emil
It's goingpretty well!
That's a very solid start!
Yea I need to start poppingsome now
Maybe you get the airstrike
You got the airstrike!
Did I?
It's hard to control all three balls
At least I got 2 on the table!
I have a feeling that was close!
It's starting to look a bit worse now!
I literallyhave no idea where it can be - the last two ones
Now i got it!
I knew there was in thecorner!
How did this happen?
It was 3-0!
I think it has to be shorter ones
or maybein the middle
No that was just a really bad shot
It was a short one!
It's starting to lookvery bad the situation!
I have to think for a moment where might the last one be
Well, I have only taken one shortone
I think the 3 were long
The last one was short
But I hit short and long
Therefore, also in the middle
Well, there's at least one spot
That I haven't tried at least so manytimes
Which one is that?
I'm gonna show you!
Okay!
Emil, what do you think?
We'll see what happens!
Too short! A bit too short.
I think it's a short one
I just haven't hit it
That was too short
Ball delivery!
Here is your express delivery!
You ordered a hundred Pongfinity balls!
From pongfinity.store?
Yeah!
Thank you!
You're welcome!
A bit too short one
I'll change a bit
No
Not the edge of the table
This is getting really intense!
That was a bit powerful!
I know that I'm going to loose so I just tried a final jackpot!
Am I too confident that it'sa short one?
You might be
But you might not be
Emil, Otto thinkshis one is short
I don't know!
You have no idea!
I have literally zero idea where it could be!
No, it can't be there
Finally I hit it!
It was like3 times in the edge
And under the table and...
I was confident it's a short one
Winner of the grand finale!
Sensei!
Come on! The balloon Sensei!
I'll give it to you, thatwas good
Nice comeback!
Okay so we have a new video coming out every week
So remember to subscribe so you don't miss out!
And go check out pongfinity.store
for our merch!
Until next time!
I finally got his ball!